wait do you think celebrities help I
mean at these marches you know you will
course we'll wait a second because
there's a whole whole school of thought
that says the Trump people are saying
you know what celebrities go ahead
you'll get them reelected enjoy your
speaking out because that makes the
regular American out there go why are
these people who don't know anything
about wildlife tell it like news the
predator in chief and his fake news you
know they they their tactic is to divide
and conquer and so you know they don't
want whenever a celebrity speaks out
like Meryl did at the Golden Globes and
yes yes and get the reaction from our
president elect
I mean was ridiculous but you know that
she hits a spot yeah watching this but
well it's not hard to do that but but
yeah that's true but look what if I have
I have been a celebrity for a long time
yeah and I have and I have been told
that I should shut up because I was a
celebrity but what celebrities can do is
that they can bring attention to things
that would really get attention you know
what do you what do you say to the
right-wingers should call us sore losers
because that's the other thing that
sticks in my craw we are not sore losers
it just so happens that we understand
that because of climate change we don't
have time to make mistakes right